Katy's absolutely lovely to see here at
collective area today I've been enjoying
it so far
oh absolutely terrific had a wonderful
day I mean because it's very warming to
one's little soul to be able to sign and
hug and you know see the joy on people's
faces and because you've got tiny little
kitties who were watching but the Sarah
Jane Adventures and then you've got the
older ones in the alert and then the
grandfathers you know my age group and
it's wonderful and you see whole
families and that's the thing about
Doctor Who that you know it rings
together families in so many cases
because it used to be a show they'd all
sit down and watch it and we've got out
of that habit in television now
everybody watches everything separately
in another room and the one thing about
Doctor Who it does bring the family back
into the same room you know sharing the
same program because when they did the
announcement of the new doctor which I
was on I actually got me moment and it
was it was a joy because you suddenly
got all these people in this country are
all gathered around the television you
know what average even people who don't
really watch it everybody gathered to
see who was going to be announced I mean
it's quite extraordinary absolutely
extraordinary it really is you mentioned
the new doctor of course we've got Peter
Capaldi going to take your time at the
TARDIS what do you think about that oh
absolutely marvelous because I mean you
know to be honest with you every year
well every year whenever there's a new
doctor we get the same old you know well
why can't it be a woman well it can't be
a woman because it was written for a man
and it doesn't do anything to our due to
women's liberation to actually just cast
it because makes a mockery of it
and you know what you need for the
doctrine what they always had and the
extraordinary standard that has been
kept right from 1960 whatever to up to
now has been marvelous marvelous
creative actors young or old and Peter
Capaldi I think is going to be he's a
terrific actor he's a character actor
and that's very much the requirement for
Doctor Who you know Matt Smith as a
young character actor I mean it's just
remarkable and he is going to be
stunning and anybody who stops watching
because he's not I candy really doesn't
need to be watching the show anyway you
know but I think when they see how
remarkable this man's going to be in as
they say you know Jon Pertwee was not
exactly a young man but by god was he
attractive you know the power of the
doctor that's what's attractive
invention Jon Pertwee there what was he
like to work with
oh I mean he was funny he was creative
he was loving he had a very warped sense
of humor like I have and we also he
encouraged me because I do voices kind
of known from my voices and so he
encouraged me to do them I used to just
do them fun so we used to when we were
driving to location together we'd create
all these amazing characters after names
that we saw on signposts and things like
that
we had the best time he really was and I
learnt as an actress so much from him
because of his experience and the years
and he went back you know in terms of
you know doing vaudeville and all those
kind of things which were before my time
and you know it was extraordinary I mean
he really was a lovely man and for him
it was his first really straight role as
an actor and it meant a lot to him and I
think it showed
in the magnificently carefully placed
performance you know wonderful wonderful
man of course obviously you a companion
to him on the show and how did you go
about creating your character and how
much kind of input did you have thing
into things like the look of your
character
well it was my second job as an actress
I was very young and I was playing a
character who you know who basically
left school done a year's training at
which he'd failed on every level very
miserably you know a little bit of
escapology and things but you know that
was a great thing about her character
she wasn't that you know she was
academically very clever and I was given
the part with no absolute you know
ground rules of how she should be
playing I did lift my voice up slightly
because it was a bit deep my voice John
used to call it the lorry drivers out
quick we'll have to retake on that so
when when I do the audios now I do what
I did back then which was to lift my
voice you know just to make Joe more
kind of girly less good and it sort of
grew because of you know obviously there
were the guidelines that she'd been
given you know when he says oh I thought
you took a level science and other and
she said well I didn't say I passed and
what was lovely Joe was very young when
she went into it you actually watch to
grow up right in front of you on the
screen you know she started to get a
little bit more kind of self belief in
herself and she started to you could
just literally see this girl grow up and
and start to she was what was ugly too
about Joe was you know I think she
hadn't she was funny you should quite
feisty she was I think I may be right
and say I don't think there was any
other Doctor Who girl who offered her
life for the doctors as many times which
meant she had a great recognition of the
importance of what he was doing in the
universe and I think the fact that she
went off and went up
Amazon and started to fight to save this
planet was her way of what she'd learnt
from the doctor she wanted to put into
this planet which I thought was kind of
wonderful and she was you know she was
wonderfully brave and she did what
companions should do she got herself
into trouble so he could get her out you
know if your companions too smart and
too capable it takes away that what what
do you do you know and yes so I think
the companions are very important on
that level and it's a sort of you know a
sparring partner for the doctor
you know you like with comedians you got
to have one who gives the feed and one
who gives the punchline you know but I
love to and she was also very much at
the moment you know with the clothes and
the rings and all that kind of thing you
know she was nice she was cool
she was definitely cool I think so too
I mean if you could come back in the
show now or in the future would you like
to do that and what kind of part would
you like to play when I came back in the
Sarah Jane Adventures with Matt Smith so
I think that's cool coming back really
and I think what Russell T Davies gave
was absolutely the perfect story for Jo
I mean she just dropped these wonderful
children that named them after towns
like San Diago you know whatever you
know she chained herself to Robert
Mugabe she was you know he was they were
fighting to save forests and so on and
so forth and yet she was still very Jo
you know she was still kind of funky and
there you know granny groovers so you
know I don't think I could have been
given a better storyline in terms of how
the character and the fact that she had
stayed with her professor with cliff you
know because she was so loyal to the
doctor she would have been loyal to her
husband you
had 13 grandchildren and I just thought
it was marvelous and to work with Liz
who I had was good friends with and I
just you know to me she was the
quintessential Doctor Who girl in a
sense I really thought she was
extraordinary and she kept that
character so strongly for so many years
you know and for us to work together and
she's it was great because her character
is quite serious and she's it was lovely
having Joe's character that can she
really lightened it all up you know and
it was a joy to do and to work with
extraordinarily creative Matt Smith I
mean what a treat so that means
basically now I worked with Pat Rotten
William Hartnell Jon Pertwee Matt Smith
and on audio Colin Baker and Peter
Davidson so I've had quite an innings
here girls that's credible isn't it not
many people can say that no no darling
I'm just a doctor groupie that's me now
how do you find the whole world of these
big finishes of audio plays the Doctor
Who what you enjoy about those in
particular I think it's marvelous I mean
I actually originally refused to do it
that's why I was very late coming into
it I mean also I've been living overseas
for a lot of years but every time I came
back you know they say we're and i said
no i can't do joe without John
absolutely not
um I wouldn't even know how to start and
then one day I read this particular
script and I you know I get to play John
and I get to play the brig and I get to
play the master and every other male and
I she was literally David Richardson
said to me he said well she's right I
went straight into her you know it was
like right there in the filing cabinet
of characters you know because my life
my career has been completely diverse
since then
and then when I was doing the iris world
time of course you know which I started
out with Peter Davidson and I did we
gone and I said I wanted to put her with
Joe as well so that was lovely and they
let me do that so it's been very
exciting in London doing the scorches
which is completely bonkers one which I
have to keep saying to every much as I
caitli respect Melvin Hayes ie did the
score jeez it was me doing cool cat and
all those other voices because that's
what I love doing but so I've been given
some really kind of quirky ones and then
to have Louise Jameson direct me and
then I had Sophie Aldred as a guest in
it I mean it's just wonderful I love it
and I think Big Finish of dancing
absolutely amazing things because they
kept Doctor Who going actually when
there wasn't you know quite the height
that it has around it now so they're
really you know respect there they
absolutely do and I know that the fans
all the fans of show absolutely believe
that too and they love them for that
talking about what kind of life and the
craziness of the 50th anniversary year
we just had recently a mini episode with
Paul McGann returning as the doctor and
what did you think about burns I think
it's terrific I haven't seen it oh it's
a lovely actor I never saw his doctor
who though because I was out of the
country he from 1982 to none I was in
America in the 90s I don't know right up
to yeah five years ago I mean I saw when
Christopher Eccleston came out of that I
went yes we're back it's running and it
needed that rest in my opinion it needed
to stop and it needed to change and to
grow up which it stunning and Eccleston
was the best act you could have chosen
at that time for that mo
followed brilliantly by tenant and so on
as ever but he was the perfect one to
open the door I think and the writers
are terrific and you know wonderful the
right produce I mean if it hadn't been
for I don't think you would have been
for without Russell I don't think we'd
be having the 50th today to be honest
with you I mean I think he was
absolutely and now of course you've got
the wonderful Moffatt I mean there's
it's an extraordinary thing and it's
done really well and I know that I will
eventually see Paul McGann but it was
completely out of my time because in
living in an Australia in America I
wasn't getting it like you were getting
it over here in fact we did a quiz that
they did for a newspaper the other day
and I did I did really well in it
considering I've not seen it I didn't
see myself in it no I never watched me
in it no I did it but I never ever saw I
didn't start seeing them until I start
they were putting them on when we were
doing the DVDs and doing the talks and I
was sitting there quite gobsmacked
because I hadn't seen them for that long
um and you know I have great respect for
everybody who's been it wonderful actors
Colin Baker you know I mean that hasn't
been a there hasn't been a weak link in
this chain right up to Sylvester but
this show needed a rest you know and I
know from what I've been told McGann was
absolutely marvelous so I will
eventually get down and have a little
look e because people are sending me the
links so I will say it now you mentioned
that some you kind of didn't watch
yourself and you went back when for the
DVDs what did it feel like we're living
those moments all moan you know it's
probably more exciting for me you know
because I'm one of these people I love
life just to get to be there to happen
it's an adventure you know and because
it's an actress when you've done
something you've done it and you move on
I mean you don't keep going over it and
over it and looking back on it and I
you know the thing the television when
you've done it is that if you haven't
done it very well you can't change it at
least in theater you can sort of go back
and change it and you know my life just
sort of moved on it just sort of moved
on and so coming back and sitting in a
studio um with that going on it was all
such a wonderful surprise and working
with people like only on the DVDs like
Barry Letts and things like that I was
learning and I was always interested in
it when I did it I used to go into the
editing suite um and I think nearly
Adria microphone I used to go into the
editing suite I mean I hung out with you
know Brian Hodgson from you did all
those wonderful so I've always been
really interested in the technical side
as well because I think as an actress
you know everything that I'm doing
should be a part of what I'm interested
in and so going back and seeing this and
learning us open this whole new door of
of excitement and and kind of I was
exploring it almost really for the first
time again and that was one of us met
when I was doing the commentaries I was
doing them absolutely in the moment and
you know it was very very exciting
whereas I think if I'd watched them over
and over again I think I'd have been so
over myself let alone you know and you
start to see all these wonderful acts a
secret hadn't seen theism so everything
was coming so from my heart and it was
like when we did the green death and I
was and I just burst into tears because
it was the first time I realised I
suppose you know I've read it
have been sort of a couple of years
after but it was the first moment that I
actually took in that my beautiful John
was not here anymore you know you don't
always deal with things straight away
and they said you want to do that again
and I said no it is what it is you know
because that was absolute from my heart
now I don't think any of those for me
would have been the same if it had all
been seen and I knew what was going to
happen and daddle it up and I think so
they come out quite raw and I say some
pretty outrageous things maybe but you
know it it was a joy and I'm seeing all
the actors that I worked with all those
years ago and it was like it only seen
them five minutes ago I was and you know
and to see you know that the wonderful
Roger Delgado and the wonderful Nick
Courtney you know and I still have my
lovely Richard Franklin and so on but
you know to see these people that I will
never actually see again it was joyous
and sad and but I was thinking to myself
all the way through it you know what a
wonderful job how lucky was I you know
so lucky
we really are and it means a lot to the
fans as world and the views of the show
that it feels like that for you as well
I'm sure finally you mentioned earlier
that you're part of the show that
revealed Peter compelled is a new doctor
in was it meant to you to feel part of
this 50th anniversary year celebration
you know
I was thinking about all of this you
know and how weak people keep saying how
do you think it's logic wonderful thing
about this show is that obviously you
know the passion and the creativity
right from the start of this
extraordinary concept I mean it really
is beautifully wacky isn't it you know
hey if I got an idea for you okay this
guy's got two hearts he flies around in
the police but you know sorry what do
you on but you know it's a wonderful
concept and the teams that have done it
have all been so passionate then that
includes the act doesn't you know my day
there was no computers all the work that
went into getting those special effects
and to create something like this and
you look back on it and it's damn good
for even back then without all of what
we got now and people work so hard to
get things because you couldn't just
press a button and that so that keeps
the show like that and then all the
people that were young and watching it
that are now working on it writers
Russell T Davies you know summit rob
shimon all these wonderful right Steven
Moffat these were all people who were
fans so you've got this incredible love
that's gone right the way through it but
then one of the most important things
that I think would we be having this
50 years if it wasn't for the
extraordinary France which now span not
just Australia and America but I'm doing
this thing on Monday which is for
Brazilian and Argentinean and Russian
and you know and I'm getting all these
to eat I mean this is just mind-blowing
so the fans and the creative teams
behind it that's what keeps this show
and the fact that I think we all sit
down my me right since we were in caves
and I think we've all looked up at the
sky and thought I wonder what's up there
and I think that's the universal appeal
you know and doctor who was the first
thing to really recognize that and put
it on television and the fact that I'm
still here you know and that is having
its 50th anniversary you know who knew I
mean I know that we saw a cult thing
happening when John and I were in it we
could see that it was going to go there
but you know I would never you wouldn't
have put tuppence on a bet if somebody
says would you think this would be
running in 20 years time you come there
but you know and it's I call it the
Doctor Who kiss is that everybody who's
ever been involved with it that's what
it's like it's like this extraordinary
thing that I just happened to call the
doctor who kiss once you've been kissed
by this show you are with it forever in
one way or another and that is
remarkable
yeah my place it's been absolute
pleasure talking to you thanks so much
your time to dirge
thank you very much indeed thank you
you